okay awesome
um well welcome everyone to the
september 2021 pi data triangle meetup
um glad to see everyone's joined after
so long
[Music]
i was saying we had 120
rsvps
i was curious to see how many people
were serious about it
well maybe the numbers will go up as we
start the presentations
um
but yeah thank you everyone for joining
um first off i'd like to thank the
sponsor
um
used to be velas's digital now veracast
data driven data-driven marketing
communications um so thanks vericast for
sponsoring
and we it used to be a bigger deal you
know it right now all i have to do is
start the zoom meeting and that's it
yeah it really used to be like a buffet
and a room and you know
all the good stuff but uh we'll get back
to that eventually i'm sure
uh we're trying to open our offices
before the end of the year
um but
i'm just not sure where we're gonna get
back to uh
you know breaking bread together but
sooner the better
yeah and i guess for now we have we have
the zoom link
hit the zoom lead
um yeah and thank you to our other
sponsor num focus uh num focus is a
non-profit that promotes open practices
and research data and computing
um yeah as always i'm sure you see
you've seen the code of conduct before
but
as a reminder pi data is dedicated to
providing a harassment free experience
for everyone so please be kind and
professional
as we always say don't be mean be above
average
um and a quick reminder that our next
meeting is november 3rd 2021 at 6 p.m so
we're still a bi-monthly conference at
this time
um yeah i just wanted to take a moment
to ask ask everyone like how can we best
serve content that you want or need so
what data science topics interest you do
you know anybody who would like to
present on a talk
are there any activities you'd like to
organize
any local data science resources that
you want to engage with
we're really looking for presenters to
fill slots for the next um next few
months actually
um so if anybody you know or you
yourself are interested in speaking
please reach out to
mark through gene or i via meetup or
email or linkedin and we'd love to
speak with you
i want to make a point that it does not
have to be a long presentation we we
are very flexible especially while we're
online about having
a smaller smaller link shorter length
presentations
20 to 30 minutes as opposed to an hour
or more
yeah definitely
um yeah i also wanted to ask this at the
beginning um as you guys know the last
like 15 minutes or so is dedicated to
lightning talks and so a lightning talk
can be um
like a five to ten minute or even less
than that uh talk uh ranging for for any
data science topic or any in any format
um so this could even be like sharing
something interesting you learned this
week so if anybody is interested in like
speaking for a few minutes at the end of
the conference um please let me know in
the chat and i can
create a list of speakers
um yeah and finally i wanted to take
this time to ask
ask everyone does anyone have any event
announcements or job opportunities
they'd like to share
[Music]
well vericast has
two open
senior data science scientist positions
um and um
i believe there's a couple um
uh data engineering and software
engineering positions open
uh in various places uh most of our
positions are remote now so
um i know most people here are local but
um
you know you could see our open
positions on
the vericast
website
awesome yeah and i actually got a
message from taylor england from rasgo
um they are looking to
looking for a strong python developer
who are interested in data science and
machine learning
it's a remote job opportunity and i've
posted that link
in the chat as well
yeah um so elucid bio imaging
e-l-u-c-i-d
we're hiring a uh python um
uh a python developer senior python
developer i believe um and there's a
contract and full-time role the con the
full-time role is in boston so you'd
have to be willing to relocate to boston
but the contract world role may be maybe
remote so um
yeah that's another one and it's it's ml
ish i mean it's not doing ml directly
but it's working more for the
engineering side but it's it's
ml adjacent
awesome thanks
sure
yeah anyone else
cool um
yeah otherwise i guess we can get
started
sorry hey this is matt meinel um
yeah i worked for a company called
boto.ai we just got our
series a closed this week we're hiring a
bunch of python people we basically
do uh
auto parallelization for pandas for
python pandas
um
it's like a big compilation engine
compiles your python turns it makes it
parallel
speeds it up
apple's using it it's pretty big deal
great thanks
cool um yeah let's get started on our
presentations so
uh first up is daniel wagner uh daniel
started his career on mobile app
development and has since then built
countless large-scale e-commerce and cms
projects
before diving into the world of fintech
in the last five years
um
daniel currently leads the data and ai
team at sensibile and he'll be talking
about building a state-of-the-art
inference pipeline on aws sagemaker
uh daniel take it away
hi everybody thank you for having me uh
it is daniel um but um
let me share my screen um
so sorry for the mouthful of the title i
was
preparing for another conference and
they had
um let me just present i'm going to
present the remote and they had
that as a suggestion of the topic so i
took it but i
now realize it's a very of a mouthful so
as
going i'm going through the presentation
uh
please feel free to stop me at any time
ask questions uh it's going to be very
very boring if i'm talking about myself
for an hour so stop me at any time ask
questions um should be reasonably
interactive
so let me start quickly about myself
so on personal side uh
try to like biking this is me on a one
foot
drop
being terrified so
i like biking unless i'm good at it uh
as a professional background i have a
masters in engineering um i started my
career as a software engineer uh in a
small company friends that i went over
to lead a
an office in brazil that where i'm from
um i
i stayed there for about 10 years
it was mainly focused on e-commerce
then i left because
once you get away from brazil about a
year after i left
they were
bought but over by capgemini so i guess
my leaving helped
um
and since uh for about since
2016 i'm leading i'm at sensible
starting my career here uh
on the delivery side so sensible
is a b2b company uh and so my role was
to make sure that our clients were well
integrated that i would understand uh
what they were doing
um and how they could leverage our
software better and then uh
for the almost two years leading the
engineering function
more particularly the machine learning
team
um so this is about me this is my
linkedin if anybody wants to connect
more than the glacier
so i want to talk in terms of flow i'm
just going to talk a bit about sensible
uh about what our journey has been uh
talk a little bit about our data what
does it contain and what stories we can
tell with it
uh
sorry any questions
um then i'm gonna walk a bit uh how was
our journey to actually build our system
from scratch uh and uh actually getting
a bit more details uh into
what we've done and then opening for
questions but again stop me at any time
uh
yeah don't want this to be one hour
monologue
um
right so
i'm going to briefly go over what
sensible does
so
first talking about
who we are especially being a b2b
company i think it's important to say
who we serve
so sensible is a company that does
receive management for banks that's kind
of the beginning of our journey so we
are deployed with chase
so if you have a chase app
and you go to your accounts you should
see an option to manage your receipts
and that's us
we also are deployed in
the largest largest syntax in the us so
ncr
fis um as well as some major banks in uk
so rbs netwest a big presence in canada
as well
so we have over 60 million customers
worldwide of course chase is the largest
one
and to them
what we offer is the possibility to do
receipt management for their users
um
in terms of
the tools that we offer
is we offer a mailbag
receipt capture in management for their
users
and so if you again are personal a
personal user what the usage that we
typically see is that
picture people take pictures of the
receipts and they can be leveraged to do
budgeting so somebody
goes to the grocery store every week and
they want to
try
to
see how their expense fluctuates or they
want to keep tabs on their costs uh
that's a typical usage
and there's a very strong use case as
well on the small business side uh when
we see people using receipts for a
variety of reasons
so
on the screen here you can see keychain
renovation that could either be a
personal use case
but we can also see lots of contractors
the user system to address these two
folders so
for instance they are doing a work on
one address 83
delta lane and then they can actually go
uh and add all the receipts there and at
the end of this project
they could ask for a refund for the
expenses or they can manage the control
of their
of the workers better
so those are
some of the key use cases that we have
because of the
small business use case we allow easy to
export an integration accounting
software so that's again a very typical
use case so rather than keeping your
receipts in a shoebox you can take a
picture they are automatically on your
bank account and by being on your bank
account
um
every banking reconciliation is a lot
easier
what we can also do with that
is
do
alerts and so for users
we can do a
reminder of when your warranty is going
to expire or your when your return
window will expire so by understanding
what's on that receipt we can offer a
lot of facility
for the user
um
i see a question of things for the
organizer so um
this is again uh what we offer let me
just put this image to my site here
so
given that we are offering that utility
and we can actually unpack those
receipts uh we can actually go and then
offer spend insights uh to the users so
given that uh we now have a collection
and that we understand the users a bit
better so we know
that mark went and bought bananas and
apples
and then the next week he also bought
that we can understand a little bit more
about him
and with that information uh we we're
not only enhancing the banking uh the
the utility of the banking app to the
users but we're also going to be able uh
to understand the users better um
and by understanding the users better
what we can do uh is start to offer
insights and
those insights can be as simple as uh
mark likes to eat fruits every week but
it can be also triggered to life stages
so we can attack that somebody is likely
expecting a baby
if their behavior changes and we can see
that now they buy pregnancy related
products or that we can actually see
somebody buying diapers and somebody is
trying to be cost conscious
and
that's for activities that that reality
what that allows us is to
change the way that the bank connects to
their users so one of the biggest
difficulties with banks
today is that they are
they're good at actually opening
accounts uh and they have promos related
to
i don't know uh
give you like a cheap credit or we're
gonna give you like
like an ipad if you open an account with
this but they have a lot of this
difficulties actually understanding
their users and creating a relation with
their users so
banks are falling more and more
under the same
youths dumb utility as the telecoms uh
which they are right because really
nobody cares who your phone provider is
all that you know is that they offer you
a landline and they offer you internet
and that's pretty much it uh and banks
are pretty much going down that path
that's banks are just a place where you
keep your money um but that's it like
people don't have a relationship and
what we're trying to do with our this
spending science product
is allow banks to have a relationship
with their customers that's a lot closer
to the relation that
amazon has with their customers so
amazon truly understands who you are
because they have access to all your
data and they actually leverage that to
offer you contextualized information
contextualized promos and that is the
type of relationship we're trying to
to create
question
yes on the side you've got life stages
behaviors triggers and needs what's the
difference between a behavior and
a trigger
so
like what would what would be an example
of a trigger that's not also a behavior
right um this is more this this page is
a little more focused to banks when we
say trigger we're typically saying
trigger to an action and so because our
system is real time or near real time
uh a trigger could be hey we just
detected somebody bought i don't know as
a a luggage or they they just bought a
door crawl so they're likely going to
travel somewhere
you should leverage that that insight
about the user and offer them travel
insurance or something like this so it
doesn't make sense but one could argue
that's a behavior but it's fine to call
it a trigger so then what would a
behavior be if that's not a behavior
yeah again this is how we're actually uh
this is perhaps more market position but
i agree with you that that's a behavior
but on our system the way that we're
calling it a behavior would be something
like
understanding your user better so i know
that ron likes
uh outdoor sports so we always buy uh
he every other week he will buy some
fishing equipment uh so that he can go
there and and so where the way that we
trigger internally a live stage is hey i
just realized that ron bought a house or
had a kid or grandkid or something a
behavior is a bit more understanding of
the user i can see that you're an
outdoor sports enthusiast
and based on that we can fit you in
different profiles and the trigger will
be more like a pointing time thing so
that is how we are splitting so behavior
is kind of like a categorized trigger
pretty much like he always buys outdoor
hunting equipment or fishing equipment
so that's how we trigger our system and
this is a lot on how the buyers are set
up on the on the bank side so how they
do wanna how they plan to use that data
that's more how we trigger this
thank you
thank you for the question
daniel i have a question about the the
size of the banks have you found
any difference in the kind of user the
sensibility user
based upon the the bank that they're
banking with
um
so just me let me see if i understand uh
if we can see difference in behaviors
based on if somebody is making with
chase which is of course a
a monster versus
quantic that is a small
local bank is that the question
right a small a community bank a local
bank a a state level bank
mid-market whatever what a small market
bank as opposed to a national bank
so
the behaviors
we do see behavior somewhat consistent
across
the behaviors are a little bit more
centered on geography
uh then they are necessarily on banks so
a chase customer from chicago is likely
behaving more similar to
mid first bank that's also in the
chicago area so
that behavior is more there
from our perspective the way that this
data is consumed though is very
different and something i'm gonna
talk later the way that we pack this
over
chase would expect a lot more raw
information and they want to do a lot of
the data science themselves but somebody
like a smaller credit union will need
something a little bit more ready but
from a end user behavior
again it's based on the data that i
remember it's more related to the
geography
than it is to
the actual institution they're banking
with
i i'm assuming i answer the right
question uh please uh oh yes thank you
okay
thank you um
right so this is our product um and so
just an example uh one typical user that
we have on our system not one type one
example of a specific user that we have
on our system so of course names and and
everything else is fake but uh for
olivia we know that based on olivia's
receipts uh she spent over five thousand
dollars over the last two months across
a variety of merchants
uh we know that she bought multiple kid
meals at fast food disappearance so
and some adult meals as well so she's
most definitely a mother we can see that
behavior
we can see that she buys um
she's in a teaching profession based on
the level on the books and the details
of her purchases
and we know that she's likely
trying to do something on the side so
she bought the internet domain and
there's quite a few triggers there
so
what we are trying to hear is
trying to teach the bank on how to
engage with olivia in a way that's
meaningful to her versus hey olivia is
30 and because she's 30 we're gonna
offer her this
home savings plan or this uh now the
behavior can actually be if we know that
olivia is a teacher well maybe whenever
there's a new government legislation
associated to
the geography where she is
we can say well if for your tax purposes
maybe you should save these types of
receipts or we can actually give
insights and maybe this
type of savings account can actually
give you a better return in the end of
the year
so that is an example of
one user and how the bank can actually
start to interact with that user in a
way that's interesting in a way that the
banks become more than just utility
providers but they actually become a
trusted partners i think that's a lot of
what we're trying to do
yes
i have a question
about how they know these things so is
all of this
like um okay so book purchases so the
first bullet she bought multiple kids
mills okay so that came from
fast food establishments yep
how do they actually know
what she bought
like okay if you've got if you're a bank
and assuming she paid for it with a card
you've got a fast food establishment
receipt
yes
you have it itemized into kids meals
versus adults meals yes so the way that
it works is that again this is
so this is a fantastic question let me
unpack a few things so
um
whenever we're building machine learning
we have true and to be very much aware
of the responsibility of managing data
responsibly and how we can actually do
things in a way that's uh
that's useful
nobody has any
very few people have weird feelings
about how amazon triggers you because
what you know that amazon is offering
you like in my case like barbecue
equipment because i always buy something
related on their website uh so i'm not
triggered at all that they know that
that's an interest of mine so
whilst on the other hand somebody that
gets an ad on facebook or twitter
it's a lot creepier because they are
getting that data from different
websites and disparate places the way
that we get
customer data
is by
olivia taking a picture of her receipts
and submitting that to her bank
so the way that we're getting this data
is self declaratory so levi says i want
to manage my finances and
my bank offers this convenient feature
in which i can actually take a picture
of my receipts and then i can get the
itemized data and based on this itemized
data from olivia
we can see
that well she did bought fast food and
then we can actually run classifications
on our site and say well we can actually
see the classification of every single
one of her line items and based on that
we know that she bought a happy meal
that we could classify as a kid's food
in a big mac that could be a teenager or
an adult so yes we do have access to the
itemized data but is on a
self-declaratory
way instead of there's us snooping
around
okay so just to clarify but if if i paid
for something with my debit card or my
credit card and i did not take a picture
of my receipt
would you have itemized
no information okay
so the reason so all of these
every single one of these four bullets
comes from them taking a picture of a
receipt and submitting it to this app
so
the
and you take a picture yes so this will
be part of your banking app uh in as
part of your banking app yes you can
take pictures you can the sources can be
multiple you can you can actually have
if you have an email with the purchase
you can also send that in or a pdf like
the sources are the most common still
paper by far
but that is the
but yes so
thanks for clarifying that yes uh so
again it's important to say in the i i
saw the questions from thomas and
johnson i'll get you a second so another
reason that
sensible chose to offer these services
to a bank
is that there's very little
[Music]
there's
people typically trust their banks
through the safe keeping of their data
so
most people
know well my bank already knows how much
i make and where i spend my money
typically they don't feel a weirdness
factor about submitting more data
so that is also why this is the path on
all the user surveys people wouldn't
object to the making knowing that
information so the question from thomas
was what is the incentive
to itemize for a consumer and that is a
fantastic question so
first als it's important to say that our
solution doesn't have the goal of having
100
of anybody's receipts and the goal is
not for everybody to take a picture of
every single receipt people people
typically take pictures of receipts for
specific use cases so in case of olivia
what is very clear is that she's a
household budgeter
meaning that
she really tracks her food purchases
especially every time that she goes out
as well as when she goes to grocery
stores so she's clearly using this as a
budgeting tool so that she can actually
see and refer what it is that is
actually a quite common use case
there's other use cases such as a
warranty reminder so whenever i buy
something that's a larger ticket item so
if i buy something that's more than 500
i can actually take a picture and ask
the app to remind me when is my warranty
due or when is my return window due
and that allows people just to manage
their largest purchase better so we're
getting access to part of the of the
user's transactions in the part that
they care about uploading for any of the
use cases that i have and that is
more related to a personal use case but
from a small business use case um that
is actually quite a common
then the use case is a lot clearer
pretty much a lot of the
the depending on state legislations on
anywhere that you pay
you have a receipt
you have a purchase that's more than 70
dollars you have to attach a picture of
that 70 purchase through your accountant
otherwise you cannot claim as a business
expense in the end of the year so for a
small business there are a variety of
use cases associated why you get that
you can also use that to actually manage
uh your taxes so if you are in a country
that has
a
v8t so value added tax you can actually
claim those back so there is quite a
variety of cases on the smb use case
long-term receipt storage same thing
because we're digitizing and
understanding the data yes then they can
search and say well where did i buy my
tv was it
best buy or
canada computer or anywhere you can
actually find that and you have that
easy access and that can be used for a
warranty or for anything like this
um
so the other question from matthew um
so this sort of thing banks do already
without the benefits
so from a
question of
complexity and that so
first on how we do
what do we do with the data yes
storing the data in compliance and
how we're safekeeping that's i'll tackle
that in a minute but yes we were built
to be banktof from the get-go and making
sure that we also had
uh good enough provisions to store our
data in a way that's safe
um no that's right the questions that
save the data
kind of grant the idea that the bank is
sort of our friend and just wants to you
know
use this information and only a
beneficent and way that helps the
customer right that's not supported by
reality and so now
i linked to the
huge huge wells fargo fraud case where
they
systematically deceived all their
customers right so so it sort of brings
up puts kind of a sharp point on the
kind of a question of just
is there any way to audit how not the
data it's really more the intelligence
that's gathered and
you know is there any i mean maybe the
answer is just no um this is life we get
used to it but i am curious what your
stance on you know sort of in any way
controlling or safeguarding how banks
use this information and ensuring they
don't use it in essentially nefarious
ways so
they're bad enough without right yeah
when they have
this
this
fantastic question so
let me state category that i don't
believe that banks are nice and your
friendly neighbor provider and they just
want you to do this to get uh to be nice
for you
their goal is very simple they want to
increase their margins they want to
increase roi they want to sell you more
products so the reason they buy sensible
is twofold first is a retention tool
banks are losing customers through lots
of
alternative providers and so there's
quite a few surveys that if amazon or
google created their own bank how many
people will move to them and a lot of
people would say yes and banks are doing
this first from a retention perspective
so they are afraid of losing their
customers and they know
that if they don't personalize their
service they'll die so that that's
number one but number two is
given that retention is passed how can i
make money out of my consumers better
but they know that they cannot make
money out of their consumers
just by
giving you services that you're not
gonna buy they have to be able to target
you better so from a
so yes again the object the objective is
commercial the objective is to get there
but they have to figure out ways that
they are interesting to the users versus
just
yeah in terms of a compliance and how
the data can be usage i do know for a
fact that this data cannot be used for
any loan purposes because the
legislation clearly
any legislation around loan and credit
scoring and assessment
we don't abide by this legislation so
pretty much if the bank used us to do
that they will be
they will be doing a fraud so i i can i
guarantee that they won't use it
the data is the banks so in the end i
can't but i can guarantee that it's
something that we talk about when they
are integrating that
this data is not sanctioned to a loan
perspective this data is intend to
understand the user behavior better but
you cannot say well
matthew really buys
i don't know way too many expensive
things and so i don't believe that he's
a he's a good spender so therefore i'm
gonna lower his credit score this data
cannot be used to do that uh this data
can be used to understand matthew better
but like they will be
they will be committing fraud if they
sent you so again
can
yeah again the user is the the bank is
the bank so again they will be outside
of regulatory compliance
um so
the way again the reason that they are
using us is to understand their
customers more
um from gm nesmo so does anything used
to
yes so right now the only way so we are
part of the banking mobile app so we're
part of the chase app in other banks app
but
the user the vault the submission of the
data is
is volunteer so is olivia that decided
to upload her images for her own
purposes
thank you for the questions um and thank
you
yeah
so very quickly a few stories that the
data tell so the other way that we can
use this data that is uh that we're
authorized with our contracts to use it
so from again from a
contractual perspective
the data from the bank belongs to the
bank uh what we can do with this data is
to do to use that for
uh global reporting so
once we erase which who the bank was who
the person was we can still take a look
uh and see trends on that data so some
interesting things uh in terms of
consumer spending looking into how the
span data is fluctuating uh based on
consumer spending uh in terms of
types of things people buy we can
clearly see that the behavior in 2021 is
definitely looking a little bit more uh
like the behavior of 2019 and so we
could
for the first half of the year it was
very clearly that 2020 was completely
odd so we have this report that we
publish every month which is called the
barcode report so you can go to our
website
and look so again it's just anonymized
use of the data
and just some cool usages so something
else that we did last month was taking a
look into how pet purchases
were affected by the pandemic
we do know there was a huge increase in
pet spend lots of people got pets during
the pandemic
uh
the adoption like
essentially you could not adopt a cat
because or a dog because they
they were run out anywhere because
people i guess were home and they had to
adopt so
with a banking data as it is without a
skew level data all that the banks can
tell is that
there was an increase in pathway related
spend but with our data one we can
understand
that you're purchasing at walmart were
different because now you are buying
litter now they're buying toys and when
you go to a specialty store we can
actually understand more about the user
behavior so we can see that yeah litter
was by far the thing that increased the
most last year uh but toys uh specialty
special diet food all those things are
also very clear on the data and those
are things that we can see uh based on
receipt data based on skill level data
so
any questions here
sorry is the percentages on that graph
just like
like a hundred percent like it doubled
if it's a hundred percent so training
year over year
yeah so the the overall i think that
because the pet consumer spend was over
more than doubled uh this is pretty much
how it broke down so yes like a zero
percent will be the baseline so 30
increase
uh compared to 2019. so 20 30 increase
in 2020 all niches and color double
number of treats double number of normal
foods
gotcha thanks
sorry delicious didn't decrease the
leashes only increased by 30 percent
sorry the baseline is very confusing
so
now that
i explained just a bit uh what was
how the sensible game should be who do
we serve and how do we serve
let us unpack a bit on how we build our
system
and what we actually uh
how do we how do we go about it how did
it went about it so let's unpack the
receipt a bit so receipts are
extremely dense pieces of data so this
is just like uh
our ui should do try to do labeling so
this is pretty much our system just
tokenizing a receipt
and a receipt can have up to 151 data
points which is quite a remarkable
number but if you actually break down
from store address to receipt number uh
to the line item details to the
description
amounts
there's just an incredible richness
about receipts and it's quite impressive
how much data you can actually find
in on top of being extremely dense with
over 150 data points receipts are very
heterogeneous so
now that you are kind of initiated in
the arts um if you take a look uh
if you take a look into uh
receipts from different stores if you
look from a receipt from costco best buy
targets any store that you go to you can
see that yes as a user is very simple to
see and understand the data but the
variety is quite impressive so you can
see that there are receipts that the
line items are
to one side to the other side they have
item number and they don't have item
number
uh we also know that receipts have quite
a bit of sensitive information so such
as was highlighted here there's a bunch
of data and i it is clear
that there are quite a bit quite a
little quite a lot of things that are
very sensitive not only in what you
bought but also information such as
address of the user especially if you go
to an e-commerce receipt
and so when we built our system we knew
these things were tackling a market that
had very complex very varied sense of
data as well as we were starting to work
with banks which meant that compliance
was key so we needed to be able to prove
that where data was were gonna was going
to be saved uh in a very specific way
that we're gonna have all the compliance
that necessary to work with somebody big
so the way that we started was that
again sensible was already
we're live for over six years so we
built an ml based engine we knew that we
had to support multiple formats in
multiple languages so because we're a
canadian company we have quebec so we
had to speak at least our receipt engine
had to be able to read receipts in
english refrench
because there was that variety of
receipts any rules-based approach
wouldn't work so we use lstm and we just
had a large set of manually annotated
receipts to actually get there
and again because it was six years ago
none of the big banks actually trusted
aws
and when we talk clouds and we are cloud
native per se
the only cloud acceptable by the
majority of our clients was actually ibm
which is how we came to be um
in in how the system actually went live
so
this is pretty much our sensible v1 in
how we started to be
so
when you talk about things that we learn
uh during that journey uh is
so
a few things so it's super super hard
to understand how a model is really
performing so something that became very
clear is that we were able to build an
lcm based model that got f1 very very
high
and yet in real day usage
it was actually quite challenging to see
well yeah but it's not working here and
there so
machine learning models are not notably
opaque and when we're talking about
understanding a receipt that sorry
understanding a document that is as
complex as a receipt it was very easy to
see that
the results were underwhelming in quite
a few cases but it was hard for us to
understand how to fix it
so what we started to do early on was
actually to build something that we call
evc which is engine
version comparison that we can actually
do a breakdown of all the fields
and we can actually see how different
versions of the engine compare so
whenever training a new model we're able
to see not only that the f1 score is
getting better or perhaps even getting
worse but the overall f1 can be tailored
to actually meet to the fields that we
actually care more about and that is
another lesson we learned quite early
about the number of fields so receipt
has 151 fields and
product being product the first thing
that we were asked for cool we want to
read every single one of these fields
and then we want to do everything with
them
and
that was a
i i saw matthew's question oh okay
oh
get it back in a second so
that was the first thing that we had to
go back to product which was hey
we actually have to
figure out
which fields we really care about so how
how are we going to
use this data was actually something
that we had to understand from the
beginning
and start to look into specificity
around
which of the
fields matter do we care about line item
name so if you go back a couple of pages
if the data is super complex yes receipt
date is very clearly something important
the item name is super important but
then when you go that down to
description those are things that we can
lower the usage or lower the rate when
we're actually measuring so that was an
interesting thing that it was clear that
you had to go back to product to
prioritize because it's very easy to say
i care about everything
but
being able to go back and focusing into
things that truly had more uf value
added was very interesting
um
for matthew
why models do you use to identify the
fuse of the receipt
so
we actually built an lcm so the way that
our pipeline works uh is that we
actually have in the beginning of our
pipeline we have an ocr engine
and we leverage today quite a few
different ocr engines and the results of
those uh
the results of that ocr are actually fed
into an lstm
and that lstm is actually what we
actually use to drive all the to
classify every token so technically from
a flow perspective first we classify
line items and we say this line item uh
sorry we classify the lines of the
receipt uh and so you can see that this
type is a header
and once we have the headers we have the
items and so we classify that in the
second pass we actually say cool for the
items does the item name get in price so
we just have a two step with lsdms
we don't uh
we started to study mask rcnn
more to actually try to do image
processing so before we got there uh
to clean up the results of the receipt
before it's fed into the ocr because
most ocr engines are actually built for
flatbed scanners so it kind of assumes
that the text is straight uh
and so we use our cnns to actually
straighten that up kind of move
background and etc but once we do that
the ocr
already does the detection of the
characters and etc
all right thanks
yes
so i'll go back kyle i saw your question
i'll answer that in the in in two pages
um
so
the second thing that the another thing
that we learned was that devops is very
very very expensive so the
first intuition of developers yep we can
actually create something quick it's
very quick to start a kubernetes
stack from from scratch and to just have
the services development but
building software is cheap maintain is
very expensive so
as soon as we were able contractually to
move away from ibm and there was
actually quite a few surveys recently
almost read the technologies and ibm was
i think number two after wordpress uh it
was just a nightmare we had so many
issues and it was a blessing when we
were able to finally migrate over to aws
uh and we were finally able to actually
start leveraging more of the managed
service so definitely something that as
part of our journey yes it's clear today
but like there's always the question
that any situation is very cheap so just
starting with your own host or services
chip but investing something like a sage
maker investing in the queue management
uh
built and maintained by ws makes a world
of difference in the team's capacity
so there was definitely something that
we learned in a way which we get
so
as on on part of our journey to actually
get uh
data so we just started with we have
images and again images are the most
popular view you were able to get from
images to actually
get the data and structure it
once we have that structured data
the next step that we had was
we need to be able to enrich the data
and that goes to uh
kyle's question which is
once we actually are able to structure
and all that our receipt engine really
is doing is saying line item one it is
the tax apple
um
but from apple
to actually understanding that it is a
fruit or maybe it is a phone
it's actually super tricky so we
once we have that we have to do what's
called data enrichment and that's the
question that
drew is answering
this is very tricky from a flow
perspective because effectively what we
have to do
is that we had to build a very large
catalog
and based on that very large catalog in
a lot of techniques in terms of
enrichment we're actually able to get a
proper classification of every single
line item
and based on that classification we can
actually start understanding so yes
walmart really abbreviates
they also likely actually have
a upc next through the product code but
the behavior of every single merchant is
different so best buy would have a new
pc uh walmart would have a upc
costco i believe have an sku and so
there is a specificity on how every
single merchant actually is able to
extract it and what we did was actually
have that two-step process in which the
first step the goal
is just to structure the data
understanding clearly what is a line
item what is not and the second step is
actually to do that understanding and
unpack and try to attach
everything to a product catalog so that
we can actually have a proper
classification
um
and that was one of the big problems
that is necessary for us to actually
derive all those insights
uh once we were able to get out of
lctm's pure and strategic transform
models something that again on our
system because it it is it has a real
time component people take a picture of
receipts and they expect to get the
results right away or within a couple of
seconds uh it's very interesting to see
how much
transformers models are a lot easier to
train but they are a lot happier to run
so
all those benchmark is in performance
testing in that tuning is actually super
key it was necessary for us
our quality of service
um
another part on that was actually a big
learning from us from business
perspective that
was that for the longest time we had a
machine learning team and we're kind of
expecting them to do both parts and so
to both
structure the data as well as enrich it
as well as actually understand
from apple to actually what the sku is
and what that product actually is
um
was that we were just expecting one team
to finish the engine and then continue
but overall because receipts vary so
much because there's so much data drift
uh the merchants can vary models because
we have more data into our system today
than we had in the past and because of
that there's more variety uh something
that we had to learn like it took us a
long time saying one thing those are
actually true independent problems and
unless we have
two separate themes that are dedicated
to solve every one of these problems we
will not not get to it so
what allowed us to actually start
actually understanding the receipts was
this understanding is that yes google
has the best search engine in the world
and i guarantee that the size of the
team that maintains google search today
is bigger than it was five years ago
because even if they are already the
best
on that the
the goal post keeps moving around and so
it's important to keep your team staffed
in making sure that the theme is always
working on that
and that's how we actually would you
start
both understanding how the engine works
and enriching the data and having that
separate missions in terms of teams
um
kyle did i answer your question
uh
yeah that was great thanks hey rick
okay uh i don't know if there was a
question there but any other questions
on this path
all right so from a flow perspective
once we actually were able to do these
two steps that's when we're actually
what you do to derive user insights so
from
the first level which is receipt engine
data arrangement
now that we're actually able to
understand what is on everybody's
financial document we're actually able
to build user insights out of that and
out of those user insights
um
the way that we can compose them is by
saying well we can see that
most of daniel's receipts are groceries
yes but within groceries these are the
types of groceries that he buys
and therefore we can actually start
building features at
the user level
and those features can actually
build
those insights so
i i had a question earlier i think it
was matthews on how we were actually
were able to guarantee how
how the banks would actually do this so
one of the key things for us is that
because we serve large financial
institutions and we serve chase again
our prime example
chase doesn't want sentiment to really
tell them
that daniel likes sports or that daniel
is a new parent or a new homeowner what
chase is trying to do is for us to
actually give them features that are
meaningful
on their side so what we actually doing
at the user insight level is we're doing
we're building user features
that have a lot of explainability to
them
and that is how somebody like chase is
actually using the data
they actually are able to understand
based on the features of this user store
we can actually see
an enrich with their own data because in
zimbabwe that says we only has a part of
this of this data we don't have the full
user profile because all that we said
here from the get go is that sensible
has receipts but receipts have again
whatever receipts have
from a user flow perspective when chase
creates a user
within our system
or any bank for that matter we don't
know that the person is we don't have
demographic information we don't have
contact information sensible is just a
processor of that data and we have to
feed that data back into the banking
system so
the way that our system operates is that
we can actually leverage all the receipt
data to enrich the the business profile
within the clients and now our banks can
actually have
a more detailed profile and more
detailed personas that can then be
triggered so
as part of that that journey
uh again something super important to us
was to figure out what has to be real
time and what can weight so from an end
user perspective when you're taking a
picture of the receipt very clearly that
has to be a real-time processing we had
to be able to give a quick feedback on
whether or not they get a picture wasn't
able to read your receipt and to
actually understand
if this receipt
was a grocery on what was there
but when we're talking about what can
you do with this data those are not
necessarily
real-time needs
and so this was also an important lesson
for us on this journey was figuring out
which of our data points actually needed
to be real time
versus which of the ones that could wait
for a slower processing time that could
wait uh
an hour a day
and so having that split
was actually a very interesting
separation of concerns that helped on
our data pipeline overall
um
also important to know is really focused
so something that we've been getting a
lot better at is when we're trying to
derive user insights is to actually
understand
uh based on
which are the insights that we're trying
to generate which are the features that
we have to understand so on kyle's
questions earlier on how do we actually
unpack that is also important we have to
understand
depending on the user insights that
we're trying to derive we're gonna try
to spend more energy in reaching
receipts from a certain type of merchant
or from a certain type of catalog
if all that we're doing is getting
grocery receipts then sensible probably
should be an expert in
everything related to grocery everything
related to food
and based on that
we should be able to
have a catalog that's very rich on that
but if most of our data is actually
coming from
uh if we're trying to generate insights
that are associated to electronics then
that's what we should do the catalog so
having that end user visit that end
utility visibility is key
because it allows us to focus on the
part of our pipeline that are relevant
we could probably spend years only at
the data enrichment level because again
it's super complex problem there's a
huge variety and there's hundreds and
hundreds of ways to display the data
and merchants can chose to change that
any day so figuring out how good is good
enough was actually a super important
part
uh and again the last part was pretty
much how do fis leverage this data so if
we're serving a small community bank
they need data that is a lot more
tailored and a lot more detailed because
they won't have
a data science team to actually consume
this data versus a large fi that could
all could actually get a data science
team to just get more feature level uh
data so
that's also something important from a
b2b perspective understanding if the
consumer of your data is going to have
a data science capability or not so
again something that we had to spend a
lot of energy understanding
question
yes uh when you
well that was appropriate
when uh
when people are taking pictures of their
receipts
how did they how did they take a picture
of a long receipt maybe from cvs uh or
or just
they're doing a grocery shop for a large
family so they always are going to have
a particular pretty long receipt
do they they take multiple images do
they do do a video and scan down with
the receipt what's what's generally that
worked best for your users and for your
receipt engine so that's a great
question uh
and
yes uh two houses point we can't so
first from you won't be able to see but
i have a receipt here on my phone that
is a grocery receipt
it's quite large uh and you take a
picture from far away so modern phones
are quite impressive in terms of the
resolution
and
in all honesty you have yes cvs receipts
are kind of parts and they are famous
for that for being not equal friendly
receipts uh so for a cvs receipt you'll
likely have to take a couple of pictures
and then you can always attach so yes
you could take a couple of pictures and
then we'll just
combine on our engine
um
but uh once we actually uh but again for
most receipts just a picture from far
away is usually sufficient usually high
enough resolution to able to get the
data
uh but yeah it's definitely a common
problem on a few merchants but it's more
merchant specific in the other thing is
that for cvs receipts
mainly the information that the user
would care about is that well sure you
bought some
cvs receipt is mostly a grocery store in
practice typically the information that
you really care about is clean the
beginning of the receipt because that
tail end is promotions and coupons and
etc and that utility is more reduced
so yeah those are the two questions but
yes you could have more
so
for matt the question is how much is
open source
um
so most of our backbone is built on
well the all the api is built on node.js
with [ __ ] um
most of our stuff is built over
i would say that we
we started as purely open source
um
but
once we actually got to
more manage things we privileged
services that are managed but they are
typically
we build things in a way that we could
move to a pure open source if we had to
so when we if we choose to use for
something like document db
yes it's pretty much a managed version
of mongrel
um
and we could always move back to mongol
so today
our direction is mostly to go
to manage service uh
yeah but like again all the the aws
tools are proprietary but they really
are
apache foundation tools and they just do
they
they typically
freeze a version and just use that
so
yeah aws glow
really is um yeah it's just an another
apache so there is leverage so
for aws glue we have to fix the version
of spark and then you can do it so i
would say that our stack is mainly today
on manage tools but they are movable
with a little bit of effort to choose
something managed as for something open
source if we wanted to
uh
my pleasure
uh for ron
what types of data will be added during
dating equation recess so what we're
really trying to do at the data
enrichment is should link so our ideal
status
uh we're never gonna be an idea for
everything but on the ideal status is
based on a receipt you can link every
single line item to a specific product
catalog so you can actually link
from a line item so on my example i
bought like about mangoes ideally i have
an spu link to mango on my catalog that
i know
uh the price of the
the price of how much i paid i actually
attached to a brand if a brand exists in
all of those things so ideally we can
enrich for everything there
um
it's not gonna be there so we we have to
default to as a lesser state in lots of
cases but when we talk about data
enrichment is mainly
linking every single line item to a
product catalog
um
so from johnson is
based on
so can we assign the can we actually
understand and offer people suggestions
on how to manage their money better and
again that goes back to
uh a big utility that banks are looking
for more tool is that if we actually
are able to understand at a catalog
level and at the sku level so if i know
exactly that you bought heinz ketchup at
this size i can actually make uh
we can actually
understand
where would your basket be better spent
so on my example of my receipt i bought
i don't know
probably 30 or 40 items in my grocery
store and that's the list here one
utility that sensible could offer is
looking into my list of grocery store
say well actually had you been to costco
you have saved money like this so those
are ways that the banks are trying to
get utility to the user
by
suggesting them hey if you want to save
money
change grocery store
if you want to save money wait for buy
this item in bulk in bulk those are
examples where we can actually help
users so based on
so i'm kind of doing give a conditional
answer is if we were able to correctly
map what you bought to something on our
catalog then yes then the question is
how much of that each receipt we're
actually able to to get to a catalogue
but assuming that we go out then yes
then we can't say say that you should
have bought ketchup at costco because
it's cheaper bad but because you're
buying bulk
and 100 that costco is a trap i can tell
you that the ketchup is cheaper but
everything else that you buy is not
um any other questions
cool so
thank you so so much for everybody's
questions uh i was
i would not have been able to speak for
an hour if i did not have any everybody
just
interacting and asking all about our
stuff
um how important is python to your stack
um
our historical stack is mainly based on
nodes but everything new is based on
python so
[Music]
i would say it's very very important so
everything every new thing that we put
up is based on something hyphen
so
our developers that's exactly where they
are today
mainly moving away from typescript over
python for most new things
cool
so um
yeah my
i can send a link uh of the but anyway
if anybody wants to reach me i'm sure
there's my email somewhere so feel free
to send me any questions or ask anything
else that i have failed to answer i'll
stop sharing
awesome thank you so much daniel um
thank you that was a great presentation
and my apologies for the naming mistake
um i've corrected the slides
all good
cool i think um pretty virage has joined
um
let's see
cool
great uh pretty fresh are you ready
yeah
cool you guys hear me
yes
so just a quick intro pretty virage
currently researches machine reading and
has been working in the intelligent
document understanding space for the
last three years
he's the author of three different
libraries grand former style former and
parrot paraphraser
in the past he's built large-scale
distributed data systems and works in
the technology behavioral economics and
psychology fields
and today he'll be talking about
building a grammar error corrector
go ahead
okay
okay hi
hey hi um i'm alderman
yeah we can hear you
yeah
hey thanks uh thanks for this wonderful
opportunity uh thanks for having me and
uh let me go ahead and
i'm
sharing this visit
bottom center of the screen
uh no i think mac is
okay
i see a slide
yeah okay
it should be in the full screen mode and
let me know if you guys see it
okay so that's the uh that's the topic
uh the idea is to tackle grammar errors
but uh you know you can
solve the same problem multiple ways
we're just gonna spend the next couple
uh 45 minutes or so to discuss how we
solve the grammar corrections in return
text whether it's going to be human
written text or it's going to be system
generated text by mining data from
emerging systems because uh
you know why emergency system wired why
why not conventional ways
are some of the things we're going to
talk about
uh i'm gonna quickly i i thanks for the
interaction rp but uh this is me a
couple decades of applied research i've
done some uh time in nlp data
engineering is one thing and
one of the one of the things that i'm
really enjoying doing um
especially the last couple of years is
how to put together creative data sets
uh especially in tandem with mission
mission writing that's um one of the
things i'm trying to do and
and
that's that's that's one of the that's
the crux of the talk today how do you uh
put together creative data sets uh for
this for the task especially the tasks
which are very data hungry and uh
you know
um
so let's let's dive in and uh
in terms of
uh in terms of the target audience you
get the best return on investment for
your time if you are acquainted with
language modeling a little bit of
sequence and sequence model
i will try to make it
accessible for all the audience as much
as possible but if you do have some
basic background it will be a lot more
easier and you crossover a lot more
easier uh just uh just
just how i'll share that
um so this is what we're gonna look at
uh we're gonna it's a very simple agenda
it's not a uh
that we have only a couple things to go
over
we'll look at the anatomy of a grammar
task because there's a lot of
misconception as to what actually the
tasking to add tasks itself entails
um especially uh
due to the due to the arrival of large
language models nowadays and um
i think my system is slowing down
so
uh we're gonna
look at how we're gonna what are the
different ways we're gonna collect the
data that there is conventional ways to
do is there are conventional ways to do
it and then we we can have a look at it
how we how i've collected the data first
look at the data what it looks like what
what does um you know the actual data
distribution looks like
stuff like that and then we can do a
quick walkthrough of the code
as uh as to how to uh how uh the whole
data
generation process looks like and then
uh we can look like what where we can go
from here right so that's the
high level agenda
oops i'm sorry
hello
yeah you guys are able to see the screen
yes yes yeah
okay so here is uh if i here is the
takeaway uh for you guys uh how do you
get endless supply of community
annotated unbiased high quality data
across domains
possibly from multiple languages for
free
i understand this sounds like a stretch
and it sounds like too good to be true
and if you will indulge me i'll take the
best shot and convincing you that this
is possible so uh please hang on uh for
the next 40 minutes and you be the judge
at the end of the session if it's viable
or not
so let's uh jump in right away and look
at the anatomy of the grammar
correction task um right for for for a
language i mean grammar obviously is a
very language specific uh construct and
it is the canonical um
you know it's a canonical uh construct
of a language and it is very specific to
language and
uh
as as for the linguists uh especially uh
you guys have to probably look them up
uh christopher christopher bryant he has
done a lot of work in uh you know
putting tools together
for grammar correction and as per this
definition broadly that these are the 25
categories of errors
english as the language can have
you know across competencies when i say
competency the proficiency of the
language you could be a native speaker
you could be
a beginner you know
this 25 categories of error
should probably i i don't know if i can
call it hundred percentage of all the
errors will be covered in this 25
but
a solid 95 or more uh percentage of
errors will be
covered under these categories of error
which we will discuss in detail
uh so don't donate with the details but
it's just it's just i just want to
you know put things in perspective
saying that it's just not singular if
you just take for instance just the
verbs alone there is a bunch of verb
related there's a bunch of noun related
errors and then obviously arthrographic
errors word orders there's some of them
are
critical some of them are really
important to make the language look
palatable some of them are not so
important uh we'll look at it in terms
of human writing and machine reading
what are more relevant what are more
important
in a moment
but uh to motivate and to set things in
uh
in perspective i just want to talk about
uh the problems in itself so this being
the anatomy of
grammar error correction
uh what makes grammar error correction
actually a higher order task when
compared to other natural language tasks
if you will right so one of the things
is
the linguistic nuances as you can see
right so
all the perfect verbs like creek creek
creek
you know those kind of perfect verbs
goes in a regular way but if you take
certain exceptions like sneak sometimes
uh there is an argument you can look it
up you can
people argue sneak is fine and some
people say snuck is actual past tense
and there is an article returned to
grammarly as what are the what is the
actual past tense for snake right
and then there is domain nuances uh if
if you will for a culinary world
spaghetti and meatballs uh just because
it has got an end as a conjugation
between the two words does not make it
as a plural it's a singular it's a
single entree so domain wants is
actually defined the grammar
surprisingly and also there is there is
a huge
[Music]
factor which is the linguistic variances
across the languages
uh you know
the recent paper from stanford which
basically calls all the pre-trained
language models it's foundation models
and i
encourage you all to look it up and you
know spend some time at least in the
language part to uh to understand what
exactly i'm saying by language where
linguistic variance is here so the
language is huge in terms of uh you know
what
even i found even the largest foundation
model you can solve today we'll talk
about a little more uh talk about it
more uh in a little but before that you
can look at the example like uh for
instance if you take tai uh that's
probably on the simplest side it does
not even have a concept of subject verb
agreement the verbs don't inflict there
is no peace and are there are no uh
things and things like that but if you
look at the other side the spectrum
dravidian languages have a lot more
complex rules than what you saw as 25
rules in english so this is um you know
the the logistics is inside a single
language in the linguistic variants
across the languages and the
idiosyncrasies base may make it a higher
order task we will also look at what i
exactly mean by a higher order task in a
moment just hang on with me
so so what makes uh so given that
context given the complexities given the
fact that it is a higher order task and
the 25 uh different categories for
english
and then what exactly uh what makes a
good grammar character right for a given
language uh a model that is
trying to understand all the specific
errors when i say all specific errors is
the categories of errors and the
variances the instances of the errors
and the nuances plus offering a
comprehensive coverage of all
possibilities in terms of all
generations sometimes that's the problem
because some models tend to
tend to
correct hammer errors sometimes they
have a coverage problem sometimes they
do cover all kinds of errors but they do
have a nuanced problem you know certain
instances of certain types of errors
they don't tend to correct and then i
understand the severity of it is because
obviously a subject verb agreement is a
lot more severe compared to an
orthographical error or a simple change
in the noun or an apostrophe is a lot
more uh a wrong usage of an apostrophe
and in a plural noun is it is a lot more
severe than a than a
morphological error right and then
offers an optionally after highlight
highlighting the error and possible
edits and stuff like that so this is
this is uh you know giving you kind of a
structure for what exactly uh we have
looked forward in a good grammar
effective
right given all that so
what what is the data strategy right it
looks like um you know we have
established the fact that uh this is
this is just not meeting it does not
need a lot of data but it's going to
look like a lot of nuanced data covering
a lot of different variances
so
there are a couple of different ways we
can look at it the conventional wisdom
is
you know you can put together a team of
dedicated language experts
um who write
the critical mass of realistic grammar
errors manually understanding the you
know you know the whole looking of
errors take each error and then write
the errors and then validate the error
type by coverage because uh if you look
at christopher bryant or anybody who
wrote
in the past the paper that i referred in
when i showed the 25 errors
apparently the type of errors made by
experts the native speakers as well as
you know
people who have bilingual proficiency as
well as people who are noise
obviously varies in terms of both
distribution and kind of errors and the
way in which make they make the errors
so if you want to make a really good
grammar character it you cannot afford
to have a bias towards only the errors
the experts will make are only the type
of errors experts will make so you want
to have an equal distribution of kinds
of errors made across the proficiency of
the language and also you want to make
sure that the quality of the data
because if you are gonna when you are
writing uh data set if you're gonna have
any unintended uh unintended human
errors uh which is which is possible
then whenever humans are involved in
putting data together obviously they are
prone to errors if you're going to have
some issues with the golden data you are
you are going to have bound to run into
issues so you need to you can do this
this is this is one way of approaching
it as you can see as you can obviously
see it's um it's a resource from it's
error-prone it's expensive uh to get
this done and then
there is no way
you know you can escape i mean you just
have to add people you just have to get
uh logistic experts to do that uh one
possible alternators you just have a set
of uh language experts per language
would just kind of moderate the whole
process
and then
like your amazon mechanical tests some
kind of crowd source data generate can
happen i i'm just a spitballing here at
the point i'm not sure how much
effective it's going to be but these are
the conventional ways to put data
together or um you know
there are you know people might argue
you know i have a language model which
can generate data i can come up with
some creative ways
to generate data
possible but we're going to look at it
why different ways of doing uh why those
are all either expensive
or expensive and error-prone in a moment
um so this is the conventional wisdom
and then what probably can be a you know
unconventional way of putting data
together that's um
you know that's what we're trying to uh
trying to see here
that's probably the crux of the talk
so uh for looking at the unconventional
wisdom or unconventional ways of looking
uh putting there together for granted
correction we're gonna look at a couple
of different trends uh so it's it
probably is gonna look like a little bit
of a detour i promise to survey back and
you know
tie it all back together
the first uh
trend that you want to look at is
the emergence
we all understand what an emergent
system is right the hole is created in
some apartment you know the brain cells
individually are
uh the brain together is a lot more
valuable than the individual brain cells
and same same goes band colonies and
beehives
so
if you look at
the emerge the one of the important
emergency systems of our time is how we
define truth today wikipedia has become
synonymous for defining truth and the
way the knowledge has been created
uh distributed and consumed
it has has
changed
a lot especially with wikipedia and web
now things are moving from distributed a
decent place as we speak with blockchain
and stuff so uh there has been a so
wikipedia obviously is
greater than
knowledge created by a close group of
experts and if you look at the trend it
is community generated content return
edited
and uh by volunteer editors uh you know
uh who are having oversight editors when
i say volunteers they're coming from
different domains different language
expertise and
they it goes through a consensus process
they do it multiple times
and uh to make sure that the quality is
good and
you i encourage you guys to look at the
the wikipedia entry on reliability of
wikipedia when i say reliability i'm not
just talking about quality i'm also
talking about the veracity there is also
a vandalizing uh in wikipedia but still
for our uh for our context the
vandalizing as well as the fake
information in wikipedia is not relevant
we are only
talking about the quality of the
iterations
the editors take to make sure that the
data is of high quality nature has
compared the quality in 2005 to say it's
pretty reliable they gave some something
around 1995 it's reliable in terms of
velocity as well which is not relevant
for our conversation we're talking about
quality but i'm just putting it out
there
and and
it was so good encyclopedia britannica
physically physical uh copies have been
you know seized
um so this is one of the trends i want
uh i want you guys to ruminate about and
think about so we have wealth of
knowledge uh in electronic form
uh available for us and how it's going
to tie back to us as we look at in the
moment and uh the next thing is
um
uh first is emergent system and next
trend we want to look at is uh reframing
problems i probably want to give a
trigger alert i don't want to give i
don't want to
the intention was not to be gross or
anything but this is a really powerful
example of reframing which i'm going to
show
but
if you if you guys can possibly think
about some of the powerful reframings of
our time which which
is basically
solving hard problems uh by simply
reframing the problem statements
basically bending the problem as opposed
to rolling your sleeves and moving head
on with the problem right so uh just uh
i just want to stop and ask a question
probably to the audience to think about
it
this is one of the biggest problems and
expensive probably might not think about
it if you guys can take a moment and you
know uh
indulge me what do you guys think
probably the cheapest and most effective
way to keep the airport urinals clean
um
if anybody want to take a shot at it you
can otherwise i will give the answer and
i guess uh
how about the fly model
yeah okay so you know that okay all
right so uh for for the folks who
uh did not know
uh the answers usually will be
uh you know ranging from changing the
structure you know coming up with
structural changes change with changing
with the human habits and stuff like
that right you know uh giving training
and then make sure that there's a lot of
people so
ranging from changing the structural uh
structure of the urinals itself the
parcel in itself and all the way to
changing uh the human behavior there are
different kinds of convincing systems
coming in but one guy uh thought it can
be solved differently i don't know how
many of you are aware of it he came up
with a structure he came up with a
sticker which he just wanted to put it
there and then this is uh for men and
and the explanation is pretty simple
this is what he has to say about his
classes with the jump guy he just said
you know as much as it is very uh
insulting and demeaning to the guys but
this is what he said you guys are
simple-minded and you know if you wanna
if you want to
uh you know change or distract them just
put something there and they'll aim for
it right so uh again
i'm not trying to be trusted so i think
it's a very powerful reframe a possible
retraining it's a patented solution and
it's uh across multiple air forces we're
saving ton of money for a lot of people
so why this reframing right so if you
look at uh
it's very relevant for us if you look at
our
deep learning revolution and data we
have multiple different paradigms to uh
circumvent the lack of availability of
high quality label data right so
in terms of labeling paradigms people
came up with hey i'm going to come up
with the distance distance a distance
supervision or a weak supervision and
then i'm going to derive a better model
from out of that and then people came up
with pseudo-labeling with feed models
and then in terms of learning paradigms
you know they have invented n-sharp
learning which is sample efficient and
then say this is a self-supervised
technique where label data is now wide
and then
generating more data so if you look at
different paradigms we have
you know somehow we have convinced that
we could
uh
work around or we can go around the fact
that there are no high quality label
data right but that's not the case i
mean uh
i'm sure everybody here would agree that
given a given high quality data we
probably will all choose to go for
supervised learning than uh something
else because it has proven track
recurrent really works
especially with complex model
architectures if we throw in a lot of
data the performance is going to
increase
tremendously
in spite of all these uh innovations and
fighting the lack of data right
uh
and and i'm not
this isn't a far cry by any means of
imagination any stretch of imagination
because even the big boys uh come
you know the big tech companies are
doing it uh people might know if you
guys did not know uh already these are a
couple of examples of powerful reframing
i believe everybody know the concept of
recapture and google is trying to
understand the proof of human
verification in some of their sites even
even in their search they bring the
recapture which is on the left-hand side
they basically actually ask you to prove
yourself that you're human by choosing
specific images
but but actually you are you're labeling
data for them uh indirectly so that's
that's one of the reframings and
duolingo is a translation global
translation platform and every time you
learn language and you take this and you
know translate
uh you know
to to test yourself by translating
sentences they take those pairs really i
use those as a label data so these are a
couple of different uh powerful
reframings which are in production which
are large scale which is making a lot of
sense even for large tech companies so
i'm here to argue or try to convince you
that
rather than going this way uh to work
around the lack of data how about
uh reframing
um
you know one of the existing techniques
and blend the problem slightly uh to our
advantage and solve the problem from
there so how this reframing uh you know
i'm trying to tie the idea of emergence
and the reframing together in a single
thing
um so the idea is to repurpose
flavor of reframing is repurposed uh
which is what we're going to do
so here is here's my proposal and this
is not my thought process like like i
said this is uh
i'm simply borrowing a research and
standing on top of the giant like uh
there is a
again i encourage you guys to look at
the papers uh linked in the bottom of
the slide when i share it
there has been a hypothesis around
quite some time to
look at the wikipedia edits right so why
can't we repurpose the before and after
versions of the wikipedia revision
history so
let's let's
let's pass the presentation here and
look at
wikipedia for instance
so if you if you look at a typical
wikipedia page there is a version
history
and
i'm not sure how many of you had the
chance to go look into it and there is a
before and after version and
people do all kinds of revisions right
so uh
so if you can see there are there are
reasons for there are multiple different
reasons factual inaccuracy there is
rephrasing there is stylistic changes
and grammar errors and stuff like that
so
there there are ton of grammar uh errors
which are getting fixed as a part of the
community based edits that is happening
so the idea is to leverage
the wikipedia edits the revision history
to harvest the grammar errors from those
edits and frame grammar correction as a
translation task from
incorrect sentence to correct sentence
given the
uh given the rise of natural natural
language generation models can we do
that so that's the that's the
proposition here
and uh
and this isn't like i said this isn't
my idea there are a bunch of different
researchers and
you know they're trying to prove this
hypothesis and uh
i'm just taking it and trying to run
away with this um
so yeah to try to type back together so
the before edit with that is the text of
the grammar which is going to be your
left-hand side of the uh of the text
text generation task and the right-hand
side is your after it is which is the
grammar fixed by the community
and uh but but the challenge is there is
going to be a lot of different edits how
are we going to come up with a nice
pipeline which is going to look at these
edits harvest the grammar errors and
then tag it based on the error types and
then
train a model so that those are those
are the things that we're going to look
at it but at the high level that's my
that's at a high level if you look at it
yes wikipedia has got a community
annotated data which is unbiased because
it goes to multiple iterations and they
try to maintain the quality and
wikipedia is available in multiple
languages and yes they do grammar
correction hence
the proposition multiple languages it's
in red and i'll tell you why it's in red
but you don't have to
you don't really have to spend
you know a lot of time as we saw in the
in in the
in the conventional wisdom slide where
we
uh you know probably have to engage uh
language experts and validate the data
manually and then we have to see the
spread of the data and then we receive
the competency because the proficiency
of the language across the community is
going to be a little different because
we
it is highly unlikely we're going to
have buyers i'm not saying we won't have
a bias but the likelihood of having a
bias is relatively less right so that's
the uh
that's the
this is the money slide this is what
this is what i wanted to uh mainly pitch
and this is this is the thought process
and uh based on this idea i built a
model hardware system data from
wikipedia wikipedia edits and then
harvested the data cleansed it and built
a model and it's performing reasonably
well given the budget of the hardware
and stuff but but like i said let's look
at it
let's look at the data and uh
i i hope x axis is visible the y is a
pure uh
you know it's a histogram of
all there is you know this is this is
just a couple of hundred thousand
records and and if you can see
after i filtered out all the
non-grammatical edits from wikipedia
revision history and i was able to for a
couple of hundred requests it was a
pretty good distribution uh i'm sorry
pretty good volume and variety in terms
of the kind of errors these are the 25
kind of errors 25 or 20 odd errors we
saw in the uh in the beginning
as you can see
there are different varieties and then
the count is obviously
the count of errors is obviously
different because of
uh you know if you really i always
wondered if you put a distribution
not all errors are equally made there is
going to be you know that people are
going to make more spelling mistakes
compared to orthographical errors or
word order errors and then there's
punctuation issues
uh when i harvest the data this is what
it looked like and then um
you know it's an expensive process and
i'll explain why it's expensive because
the ratio is typically freeze to one
like if you have six if i filtered uh
you know if i took 600 k data and filter
it i arrived at around 250 300 k so it's
only roughly 50 percentage data is
useful from the wikipedia edits as as
grammar data right so uh there was also
some synthetic corruption uh available
as a part of the c4 released by google
um just for perspective i also try to
take it
and blend it and see like as you can see
there is a little bit of change when i
when i move away from uh when i blend
the wikipedia grammar
data along with the c4 corruptions so
this is what it looked like
um
so
did it did it work uh did it actually
using that data did it actually
uh turn out to be a
grammar character was it able to
recognize errors yes uh it was and
uh but given the budget so we
the model that you that has been
available in hugging phase right now for
you guys to try
uh it roughly had 650 it's 80 percentage
vacated data and the compute budget is
you know a single gpu of 16 16
and the pre-trained model is not so big
uh
so given the budget uh the model isn't
perfect but definitely good it picks up
uh
you know
for an untrained uh compared to
untrained language models it definitely
picks up
grammars pretty decently uh do try it
out
um so there are a couple of words of
cautions on the synthetic c for data
on top of the wiki data i mean why why
not just
uh wikipedia alone why i combined c4
that's obviously there is a
it's a computer expensive to filter
wikipedia data hence i combined it but
there is there are some blind spots in
using corrupt c4 corruptions i will
circle back to that in a moment
please remind me if i miss it out but
before that we will
quickly look at a walk-through of what
we were discussing in terms of data
but i would
if you if you guys have any questions as
of now i can pause
and take questions if you if you have
any questions
uh so far
i guess not
uh we have one question in the chat um
yeah
yeah i'm just looking at it
do you model how long you change over
time
uh do do you model how
okay how languages changes or correct
grammar has changed significantly okay
so uh as you can see uh
the language variance
for instance any kind of antique
language usage obviously is not going to
be part of wikipedia wikipedia is
contemporaneous and what is available in
the vernacular and what is available in
terms of vocabulary in terms of the
current electron is what the users are
going to use and uh by pure happenstance
if we had any ancient writers who had
ancient styles of linguistic experts who
brings
that
arcane usage well we we are in luck
otherwise there is no intent to bring in
arcane usages or things which are a
little ancient we are not
that is not possible
um
with the proposition i have in place yes
and i don't think i can i can also
confidently say uh
even the teams who are building uh
language corrections you know i don't
want to name names you guys can imagine
what's all these are
solving these problems you probably
can't hire
linguistic experts who are still having
the
the arcane knowledge of you know the
antique language usage in terms of words
vocabulary and things in lexicon and
spectacular so that's
my answer which is
pretty much the grammar model is uh
going to be acquainted with the
contemporaries used as a language does
that make sense uh or uh is that the
answer we're expecting or is it is there
something else missing
okay
shall we move on
can you provide some examples of tokens
okay but evolutionists
hasn't stopped someday we might want to
proofread emoji usage oh yeah sure
uh
yeah okay uh
so
emoji usage so i'm gonna make a
demarcation the evolution is not stopped
and it is not gonna likely stop but the
line here is uh wikipedia is the
professional usage uh so there is
obviously uh you know there is a the
professional version of the language
when i say contemporaneous language and
there is always a casual use of language
correct me if i'm wrong emojis are not
[Music]
not part of your professional language
in the grammar character which i'm
proposing as well as people who are
proposing and not necessarily
proposing it for
casual usage even the best grammar
character available in market is not
doing any non-textual
in a correction it basically makes sure
that the text is in
the tone of the text and make sure the
grammar is affected not necessarily
proofreading emojis but i take your
point we probably have to
get into the world of emoji era
correction but for casual usage but then
again my i would argue differently
our casual users
who are doing texting and stuff with
emojis do they really care about grammar
correction i'm not
i'm not really sure who's going to prove
appropriate their
casual text messages this is we're
target the target users for gamma ray
correction today in the humans are
content creators journalists reporters
authors poets people who uh you know
students or you know people who write
papers don't attain purpose and
dissertations where the language uh is
in the is in the professional context
and it has to be of utmost quality but
then again i i take your point uh we
probably have to and i don't have a good
answer how how am i gonna get the emoji
based casual pics so i mean we could
definitely
look at harvesting data from a casual
form like reddit or something else
reddit comments and something else and
definitely we can look at it but
uh for the scope of this conversation i
i definitely did not look at it outside
of the prophecy topics
hope that answers that question
um
is that a question we skipped uh there
is another question
it says step three can you provide
examples
uh can i move on with the question from
ron or
is johnson is
okay with the answer do you have a
follow-up johnson
okay all right
uh can you provide the examples of
tokenize okay here what i mean by
tokenize this uh okay
before getting into
the example i just want to say that the
pipeline the customized pipeline that i
used uh for the purpose of this
conversation the model that i believe is
uh
get a wikipedia wikipedia review history
is available and if you guys are not um
you know aware of the fact that what are
the mission readable
wiki revisions of vk it's available uh
you know i have put in a slides here i
will talk about it for a minute and then
go back to that
pipeline so there is a bunch of
different versions uh
when i say mission readable you can
write simple passwords to take the data
the before and after version of it so uh
i will share this and
you can have a look at it the most
interesting thing is the the last one
the whole wikipedia history in the
former history i you know it's a triple
ai paper you guys can
pick and choose which one suits uh you
the best so there are a bunch of
different version variable version so
coming back to that uh so
the first step is obviously to pick uh
mission readable wikivision history of
your particular domain and um you know
like we spoke about the domain nuances
uh
15 minutes ago that the culinary domain
has got certain nuances as to what is
singular and what is plural it dictates
the grammar so if you are trying to
build a grammar character for a
particular domain uh wikipedia has got
you know different domains you can pick
and choose a particular domain than
obviously a language so i'm going to
stick to english for the context of this
uh talk
so the first step is to obviously take
that format whichever format it is uh
the wiki text is a is a canonical format
they use that is their markup language
and the example that i used i'm gonna
i'm gonna show uh how it looks like um
and so convert that into pass and then
frame it as a translation task so that
we want to put that then uh we
optionally you want to duplicate because
there's a
wikipedia is going to have a multi-term
edits uh what do i mean by that is there
are going to be multiple records of the
same things edited for multiple
different reasons
if you want to be duplicated you can or
if you want to keep it you can keep it
so that's an optional thing in tokenize
when i say tokenize i'm not really
talking about a full-on national
language tokenizer like a word piece or
a sentence sentence piece or
some kind of tokenization so the
tokenization we are talking about is
um
i think it's a
can i can i circle back to that question
in a moment if it is all right because
uh i will show you uh
in in the notebook uh in the code
actually or in the sample i'll show you
what i mean by token is just hang on
with me for a moment here
and then optionally tokenize the data
with the the the pairs that you have and
then you might want to filter so here i
want to introduce the tool which i use
which is called the error annotation
toolkit by christopher christopher
bryant who that the guy who actually
indexed
we saw the 25
errors like um
this is a good thing to look at it this
is error orientation toolkit is an
automatic grammar error annotation
toolkit
how it's
uh it uses a particular format to
annotate errors and it's got an it's got
a command line interface as well as a
python sdk which you can use
and then you can pass you can either
pass original correct files or you can
pass individual sentences to get the
output uh i'm using the apa version
uh i will show you what it can do in a
moment uh so
so circling back to the
the pipeline
uh
so we got a lot of different
not so useful and so and a little uh
useful uh grammar error correct
corrected versions of version correction
packs from that pass you might want to
filter out
uh and then you get the spread the error
spread type to make sure that we don't
have any blind spots in terms of error
type like um let's if there is no
science here you just have to make sure
that the volume that you have filtered
out
is good enough to have the coverage
otherwise
otherwise repeat your process until you
have it until you have a satisfactory
edit which is pretty much like an
hyperparameter search it's not there's
no signs or anything like that you just
repeat the process you have enough
enough spread for the kind of model you
want to build and then detoxing them
this is this is the pipeline that i uh
customized for my needs to come up with
a
high quality grammar error paths which
are detoxing ready for training a text
text generation model right
so uh let's
spoke about the different sources and
then i can um
give you a quick walkthrough i think
given a con given the context of the
talk and the time we have
uh
i just want to keep it really
crisp and
you know
so the the steps that i showed in the
pipeline is what we're going to see and
i have the files in my
google drive i'm going to bring it up
here
and i have a written simple script
that basically takes
the wiki text data that i had and if
i don't know if anybody who's
for the curious souls this is how it's
going to look like that the the source
from which i have taken the wiki data
the wiki text is going to look something
like that and as you can see the
this is one entry
uh
an id to contribute which basically says
this is the mission read mission uh
readable version of what i showed you
here right like we saw this and
uh
so let's
look at this
it's a little bit slower
so what you see here is the rendered
version right actually it has been
rendered as html the actual markup
language is the wiki text and it's going
to look once you harvest it's going to
look something like that so what what
the script that i've written is going to
do is take this mission freew format and
then you can see as you can see these
pluses and minus plus is an addition and
the removal what has been added what has
been changed entire edit is going to be
available in a single entry and the
script is going to take that
and then
convert that data into a pair right
so that's what's happening converting
the wiki edit data in pair in this step
one
i'm just taking a single example
and and
if you are interested how the data would
look like if you uncompress the data the
file that you saw
the edit file is this
and
each of those files you're going to get
a lot of
wiki english wiki so this is for english
for a particular date if you are
interested you can see this is
which state we got it from what is the
edit version and then the size of it
it's in the form of text and then one
file is what you're seeing here and you
you're gonna have per domain uh per page
you're to have a bunch of files like
that you can harvest those files and
then
per file you can go and convert them
so once you do that i have the script is
basically the generate wiki edit pairs
is what basically is doing is taking the
file that i showed you and then converts
that file into a
parallel there is that panel dataset is
basically a pair which is a pair of
original corrections
and uh
you know
so this is you know the
from the data that you saw we got pairs
of data right now and you can see that
this is
one example i
you know
we can look at more examples this is
just the left and right side where you
know there is something wrong we will
see more examples i just want to say the
pair is ready so uh people who are
asking about tokenization as you can see
there is a space between the karma
and the actual
the word in reality we will not have the
space but the tokenization here is
the errand tool which we are
using for
the errant tool we are using which is
basically going to read the text and
filter it out based on grammar errors
that expects the content
in the tokenized format so the
tokenization here is to
if you pass if you use any kind of
pre-built tokenizer like stanford spacey
it's going to basically give it a split
across and give it like this in this
format so that's what i meant here
that's an example of that
um
uh so so once you have it the next thing
is to tag all the pairs in terms of what
kind of errors a particular particular
pair what kind of error it is having
whether it's useful or not how do we
filter that but before that
we'll look at what aaron does
just want to quickly ask
um
just want to quickly ask is anybody
acquainted with errant here as any uh
has has anybody done any work uh with
aaron in this
group
probably not
i i'm gonna take that as a no
so uh i'm i'm gonna show i'm gonna show
an example here um
so
as you can see uh the meth using errant
i've written a simple method which
basically takes two sentences and it's
gonna create an annotator and then
annotates the error and give it back so
what erin does basically the python sdk
version of it is take two sentences
and obviously i've made a deliberate
subject verb agreement error and
a punctuation mistake for a question and
then i give it so basically what you see
is
uh it can locate the error in a
tokenized version
and
it comes back and says
you know the the offsets
of the token which is having the problem
what exactly the problems
so this has been immensely helpful
uh
but it also reports all kinds of errors
which are probably not relevant for us
and if you take this this is pretty much
the same sentence but the noun has
changed but wikipedia is going to have a
bunch of changes in the nouns uh which
is not really interesting for us uh so
you can i have created in real in in the
actual process of creating exceptions so
we don't filter out all the noise which
is probably not relevant in the actual
grammar correction process we are
aspiring to have so this was the method
which basically was applied in the raw
filter which is an expensive process
i'm not going to run this i will show
you the output of it so once you run
that
the parallel the data that's going to
have
the pair of the data as well as the
edits
and
it basically looks uh something like
this the process just
paraffin
oh i can show you that
it's basically going to have a column of
uh you know errors and no errors right
wherever you don't have any kind of
grammatical errors or any no no
grammatical errors is obviously a
paraphrasing change or a stylistic
change or something like that we don't
know what the differences are
but uh the examples i want to show are
you know it sounds like nitpicking but i
really wanted to show some good examples
which actually um you know
you know says that errant is useful and
capturing the errors which we are really
interested in obviously you can see the
word business is misspelled the word
vouch is misspelled and there's a so it
basically comes back and say hey there's
a couple of different spelling errors
and then there is a
verb form error
um
here right
so
so the
this the output of this step is
basically take the pair and then
annotate or tag the errors available and
then the next step is to make sure that
we discard all the sentences which are
not all the centered spare which are not
so useful for us which basically figures
out
um
that's what is happening here and once
you filter out uh based on the empty or
non-empty value here there's another
flag here which basically says here
that's what it is showing here and
as you can see this is one of the
examples which is the verb form so
ashley attempts to reveal as
it should be actually attempts to reveal
it basically says ashley attempts to
reveal so
so you can you can take these examples
run these scripts and they can look at
it and there is a lot of different
errors and you know you can see why
this distribution makes sense this was
uh you know after i
ran the pairs
tag it filtered it and then i uh
basically
came up with the spreader the error
that's what the last step is to just to
say like you know you know split the
error forms and then come up with error
forms to have a simple count of it and
then plotted it uh
circling back this is what we
this is what is what i have
so
obviously i thought there are some blind
spots in uh in the kind of error in
terms of counts for that practical
purposes i include the corruption data
[Music]
so coming back to
the pipeline that which we which we
quickly saw which is basically what we
ran through errant is the centerpiece of
it which basically helped us
filter the data and get that and then
you can just de-tokenize it and then
once the data is there it is pretty much
a sequence to sequence modeling and uh
you can think about think about any
encoder decoder model uh language models
like t5 or bot if you have in mind or if
you are a big gp or pc and auto you can
still frame it as a conditioning text
generation using gpt
um any one of them gpdx models
so either way it's just given a text
what is the target text using the pairs
you can frame it as a text free form
text generation or a conditional text
um
[Music]
so i have uh
you know
an annex which i want to
take like 10 minutes and talk about it
but before that i think it's a good
point to pause and take questions
uh if you guys have any questions i can
talk about it otherwise we can look at
the next section which is which is
basically a
an appendix kind of section which i want
to speak about it for 10 minutes uh
their
emoji translate
um
okay
did you train this one call out i i wan
uh
there's a question from
gauri asking did i train this in collab
yes one the initial versions was in
collab uh but
the more the data coming in like once
you have more than 500 k and then if you
train it you obviously have to come up
with some kind of uh
technique
uh uh like gradient accumulation to make
sure that the batch size is you know i
have to either reduce the backside is
really small you know the patching
really small and do great in the
accumulation or i really have to go for
a bigger thing so i had to i i ran out
of google collapse
even though the pro version i used i ran
out of capacity i had to use a vm so
that answers uh that i hope answers
audrey's question
did you touch the vocabulary at all
i
uh
drew you might can you
can you speak satisfy a vocabulary of
the
yeah the
vocabulary basically so i was
curious because there's a lot of like
spell errors in addition to grammatical
errors and i'm i was wondering how the
like token vocabulary played into that
sure
but if we look at the examples we can
look at it but the foundation we did not
touch the vocabulary because we are
still doing transfer learning and there
is a
wealth of knowledge is locked in the
base model in terms of the currency
by base we are just
writing on top of vocabulary that is
available on top of that we are we are
not doing anything specific
uh
to
augment the vocabulary of the base model
using the vocabulary or additional words
harvested from the pairs if that's what
you mean i'm not doing commenting or
argumenting the vocabulary model on
which we are doing fine tuning
okay i hope that makes sense
um
[Music]
if
i'm gonna wait for a minute to see if
anybody has any questions up until now
or we can go to the next section
uh which is just like i said it's just a
10 minute
like a thought experiment um this is
again a question um if i can throw it
out
uh
there are a bunch of models like you
know people are
in awe and shock with gpts and you know
models and
did you guys uh ever thought about why
can't why we need to fine-tune a model
because we have large language models
and a given grammar is a
canonical and basic concept of a
language if at all if you say by
language model the language model has to
encompass parameters why can't grammar
error correction be a simple task a
language model like gp3
or something else can solve
anybody has any thoughts uh if you can
step up
it could be good if you if you have any
thoughts why can't we simply
abstract complex grammar correction with
the most complex large language model
anybody has any thoughts
um
i
i hope not uh i guess not so i'm gonna
i'm gonna move on and say
so
here's my case like uh
large language models uh you know as of
today these are the um full i mean there
are a bunch of language models available
there are auto encoding models auto
regressive model there are encoder
decoder models and you can look it up
and then how do you you name it and
funky face has it um you know you guys
all know the turnaround time between
academic research showing up and hugging
faces and industry research showing you
having face but still
uh these are the largest models and you
can look at the training parameters and
then you can look at the training data
size and then obviously uh
you know
it looks it looks attractive and it
looks tempting to see why why not or
what what these models do learn if it is
not if they cannot learn the basic
construct
[Music]
lack of cash flow overlap i i got a
comment i'm just reading it uh the
question lack of task for laptop grammar
correction given the training data set
that is interesting task overlap
yeah
drew says
a possible reason why
large language models cannot do grammar
connection is a lack of task overlap
but uh
but just to you know just to ask you
guys back it you know it isn't you know
if you look at it if you look at it
differently
uh
if a language model by definition cannot
solve grammar what what is actually what
is it learning actually right then uh
then it then it comes up then we have to
come up with a lot of questions and we
have to see the efficacy is it really
learning something or is it really
getting good at it so we i you know i
did some research and i i you know now
research in a traditional sense and i
looked around at the ground and i see i
just wanted to know what actually you're
getting learned and then i still
encourage you and recommend you guys to
go back to the stanford uh model uh
santa paper on beyond the opportunity
and the
risks of foundation models they they
just have phrased the pre-trained models
as uh
foundation models so as you as you guys
all know that
typical auto regressive language models
are
not learning anything in terms of
anything special in terms of what they
are learning is they are getting very
good at the
given the word they want to they want to
predict the next word right so they are
basically based on the premise of a
causal language modeling they are auto
regressive for a reason given the word
what is the next version probably the
chain rule which we're highlighting here
so if you give a sentence it's you know
it basically has learned it like this
and it it can
uh
give you the probability of a sentence
given a sentence in a particular data
set and then people uh back a couple of
years back a year back they came up with
a specific construct called perplexity
which is a measure of the language model
on the data set which sits nicely on top
of the concept of entropy
um
so
outer regressive models are
this is this is what they are getting
good at amongst different things
so a basically costing language model is
is making them as a very good next word
prediction so anything that is coming
under the rubric of next word prediction
they are really getting good at so i
just want to revisit the complexities in
grammar correction and then
do one more quick walkthrough if we have
the time uh
rp i just want to quickly check how am i
doing on time we do we have
another 5 10
minutes or yes how am i doing one time
yeah you have another 10 minutes
all right
so
yeah so uh to revisit that these are
nuances right so uh what what does that
do i did promise that uh the
complexities of the language does make
it's a higher order task why a grammar
error correction is possibly a higher
order task and what is the higher order
password
so what is happening with the advent and
emergence of
complex language models today is a lot
of simple tasks
are
are
should i say not simple it could be
complex to build but a lot of tasks as
you can see are subsumed by the
capabilities of large language models
and they are fully abstracted away and
they are repeatable and they are
completely reliable uh for instance
you know
if you take classification
hugging face claims i can
reframe a natural language imprint task
to make a classification zero start
classification and it reliably works and
it it's completely you know i you can
you can take it as a perfect model and
then you can present a classification
output to the user take active learning
inputs and make it a human learning
email in the loop learning input and
then fine-tune the analyte model and
then you know a perfect reframing can be
done to make a zero shot attached
transfer and then people argue that the
qna task can be used in the zero shot
setting to transform a q a pass in the
relationship with relation extraction or
information extraction so as you can see
where i'm going with this is there's a
bunch of tasks already getting
effectively and fully abstracted away by
zero shaft by
in the in the zero shot of a flu shot
setting so let's let's take a quick look
at
what do we mean by that and what are
actually the blind spots of
um are are everybody in the group oh i
have a question
it might be able to give you a probably
glamorous correctness but correcting the
grammar is more of a perfect crazy task
okay
okay interesting so drew uh
it just indulged me for a minute and
you'll be surprised there's a bunch of
things you can see uh i hope most of you
are
had a chance to play with these large
language models like the one the
jurassic
from the
aa21 and open ai has got a playground
and they have made a very
kind of pretty bold statement to say
that
they have
you know they have three package tasks
and they do say there's a grammatical
standard error correction task that they
can support and as you can see like uh
they have given a
canned
example which basically is a simple
statement
which has got some uh
you know a word order plus the verb
errors and see you know it says
obviously it fix it right so obviously
it looks like the error is fixed and
in a zero shot setting right so to
especially to through uh it's not just
spotting the error it is actually
rephrasing the error which is pretty
impressive and it gives you the illusion
that
the large language models can actually
fix their uh can actually fix the errors
right so uh uh
i will tell you what's gonna happen here
so let's let's look at the because in
terms of
in terms of parameters
uh what's more interesting to me is
uh jurassic one is uh 178 billion
parameters so obviously in terms of
parameters this is a much bigger model
so i'm gonna
give the same example here and see
what's what's happening here
this is a completely so people who are
not acquainted with the prompt
programming that they
it's basically prompts a nice text
tokens which you can use
to tell the model without fine-tuning
the model saying that hey i have an
original sentence and i want this
sentence can you do that these are
basically prompts engineered for a
particular task and that's what the task
here is the zero-shot task here is the
grammar correction and if you can if you
can do that um that sounds great and uh
she did not go to the market so it looks
like on the surface if you breathe
bradley expands the purpose but it looks
like uh wow
language error models the language
models have figured it out and
they can actually do it right but let's
let's uh let's not just crack the
surface let's go a little uh let's dig a
little deeper right so what is actually
happening is
um i'll give you a different example but
where it is necessarily a
[Music]
sentence like this we should go we we go
should after them right and then and
then ask
what's happening
so obviously it says hey we should go
after them that's the right thing and
uh
same is the case uh if you use the same
prompts in this model which is
purportedly as you can see on the right
side 180 178 billion parameters
we should go after them as you can see
they are seemingly fixing the issues but
they're not this is this is one of the
grammar characters this is one of the
companies they are doing a great job and
i just want to
quickly show what a real grammar
character
does right
if we just simply put there
if i fix this it says we go after them
it is not saying that hey
go and shoot are in the wrong order i
want to fix the order for you that's not
what it's saying it says shoot is
redundant and it basically
the error here is if you highlight it it
says remove the shoe right so same is
the case with the model that i was um
i mean i have already ran it obviously
so it says if we say we go should after
them the correction is we we go after
them right so you can see a fundamental
difference between
a grammar model and then and a model
which has gotten good at the next
sentence predict next word prediction
right so it's not an order error right
so it's basically masquerading as a
grammar or a character when in reality
it is not i'm going to give you a couple
of more examples
to run my point right
so
let's
let's take the same example
uh let's take the same
prompt engineering and use the word so
here obviously the error is when you
have a noun which is a plural the
apostrophe is implied which is which is
not supposed to have girls an apostrophe
and an s if the correct version is uh
you're supposed to have just
just girls with just an apostrophe and
not the s and that's that's what the
grammar error models are giving you
uh
okay the model is loading while it is
loading i'm going to show you what the
language models are trying to do with
that
they have no notion of you know the
apostrophe error
it is an issue they they just repeat
that because according to them
the in terms of next word probability
it's perfect right they don't see
anything wrong here right so and then
this is only one prompt and then i
played with the prompts right so i said
like uh how about there's a problem in
the prompt i played with that i'm gonna
talk about the change of prompts in a
moment because prompt engineering is a
lot more important we have to probe the
model even though their large language
model we can probe the model externally
without fine tuning but we have to be
very creative in prompt engineering but
before getting into that i'll give you
one more example of this
uh apostrophe is a big deal and
apparently in language and obviously
here it is here it it the sentence
basically says it is the team's first
win and uh the ips is either should have
possibly it should be a contraction of
eps and it you should that will be
recognized by a language model that will
be recognized by a parameter or
correction model one which is trained in
grammar data as you can see so it is
either it is or it was right
so
yeah here the model is loaded as you can
see the apostrophe is removed in ground
former and same is the case with it is
the team's first win if you ask for a
grammar error so it is
the gram former is basically recognizing
it's a contraction it should be it is
and not on a positive or not it's
right so the difference is
uh slightly complicated i can show you
guys so
the eats and eats is one of the
complicated errors in english commonly
confused you can look it up on
but
the
so-called language models are not
are not
recognizing the error so it might sound
like i'm cherry picking and
because
in some sense we have the cherry pick
because
uh
there are 25 25 different categories of
errors in in terms of error types and
then there are different instances of
each of these errors and if you want to
really call a language model that has
understood the concept of grammar uh we
have to check every single example and
these are a couple of examples i wanted
to show uh what's happening
another example i can
show you is if you uh so for the for the
want of time if you can change your play
with the prompts it performs even better
i will leave it to you guys and also
this is only zero shot setting and then
you can do also a
few shot setting where you can give some
examples right um
for instance
if you
give this prompt
right so where i've not only given a
sentence and a correction i have a
different as you can notice there's
different forms engineered uh it's not
been default from
um
so if i give an example sorry to
interrupt if you can uh wrap things up
in the next couple minutes
sure i am i'm gonna yeah
so if you give you if you give the
example here and to show exactly what
the problem is and um
and if you ask the model to correct it
uh
the model can actually
so if you can as you can see if you give
an example as a few shots with one
example and different prompt engineering
the model does you can actually probe
the language model change it but but the
point larger point here is for the want
of time um
so
so this is what we mean by this is what
i meant and this is my argument right
like
uh at best if you're gonna do a zero
shot of few shots with large language
models you can cover 30 to 40 percentage
of a higher order task and you still
need finding that's my point grammar
correction i have tried to do it even if
you go with different combinations of
few charm zeros there's only so much you
could do with that in some sense that's
what do said there is a there is a
fundamental overlap problem so large
language models appear to fix simple
errors which are coming under the rubric
of next word production but they are not
actually they are masquerading as a
language
gamer characters they are not grounded
on sound linguistic principles
and that's the large point so large
capra they are used to train on other
models the complex model architecture
isn't is not alone enough for
doing that
so there is an op shot also if you see
that if you do large language models
in spite of substantially prompt
engineering effort you will be ending up
with a sub optimal solution and which
cannot be improved over time because you
are not fine tuning you are basically
probing the model from the outside which
is also huge models which will cost you
high influence cost and hence that's not
viable
so
so i so i just wanted to run this with
you guys so the data bottleneck can be
easily solved by reframing the problem
with wiki edits as i've done and
that's it so in terms of next steps you
just want to see like what we what we
look like if we have more data budget
harder budget
bigger base models and then if you throw
more wiki data and probably i have you
know parts to benchmark this with the
gekkomori which is from grammarly
and uh trying to extend iran for other
languages
these are some of the things i have in
mind
um
some things that peaks my curiosities
you know looking at the distribution
could there be source of bias is our
hypothesis okay and what could be the
problem by going with 100 wikipedia data
and
you know what will the
typical distribution look like and
yeah so those are some other things i
have in mind this is my next step and uh
i i think i'm i'm done uh sorry i ran a
couple of minutes outside of my given
time
if you guys have any questions
do let me know
awesome yeah thank you so much for
presenting
thank you yeah if you want to maybe post
your email
or we can continue having a q a in the
last uh couple minutes of the chat or of
the conference
um but
yeah i would just like to add our theory
i think thanks for being this is i know
this is these are odd hours for you
thanks for making making thank for us
and presenting um
you know words yeah yeah definitely
thanks for making the time
i hope uh at least you guys had some
takeaways
uh from these and you know that will be
good if you if you took away at least
one thing from this that will be good
because uh
you don't really have to have an
expensive data generation process for
correcting grammars that's
that's one thing um there is a question
uh rp if you if you don't mind i'll just
take this one question uh wikipedia
editors may already be evaluated and
less likely than the general population
uh
that's again that's the point we made uh
wikipedia errors
are a common it's a community they are
not experts in any they are experts in
the subject matter of the domain for
instance if people are writing about
astrophysics uh people who don't know
anything about astrophysics are not
going to touch the wikipedia page
probably they'll come with a sound uh
this uh knowledge
in the subject matter itself but not
necessarily think about this gauri
for hypothesis
there could be a non-native speaker
sitting in poland or russia
but they could have a fantastic
knowledge in
the astrophysics they could still be
writing wikipedia pages so
i don't think that hypothesis will hold
good that all wikipedia writers in the
community are proficient in english i
don't think so but that's my humble
thought i will leave it to you
yeah items
meant more like the distribution may be
skewed but yeah i get your point
distribution
again right that's what i that's what
i'm saying unless you really look at the
distribution you probably won't know how
it's going to look like there is there
is proficiency in the mix there is
domain domain in the mix and there is
who is doing it who is correcting it uh
i i really don't know i don't want to
speculate that if you are interested you
probably can take it offline and look at
it
um matt has a feedback i believe demo is
interesting me my suggestion is to start
with demolition
okay thank you thanks man
awesome
yeah thank you uh demo
demo by that you mean the open ai demo
or big notebook
matt i think a question for you
okay okay
okay uh but dude i mean if you have
further questions do drop me a my email
id will be with rp and i can i can make
this presentation available for you guys
and if you do have further questions do
write to me thanks thanks for uh
thanks for listening
thank you thanks again
yeah
stop sharing
yeah i think we have about nine minutes
left in the conference and we have one
uh presenter who's signed up for
a lightning talk um matt you wanted to
talk about auto paralyzing engine for
python pandas
yeah thanks um
i appreciate it uh
let's see i won't i won't
well i could throw up slides here
trying to find the video button there it
is
sorry
yeah i just wanted to make you guys
aware um
uh i've been working with a company
that's spun out of intel labs and
carnegie mellon
we are
focused on the issue of helping
particularly people that have written
models in python and pandas
or scikit-learn or
python with sql in it
how do you get that into production in
large scale use cases so what we built
is a inferential compiler that takes
pandas code and auto
auto parallelizes it and deploys it
it's called boto.ai
[Music]
we're running in production at you know
a big company that starts today
uh it's
you know you can easily run you're
taking it take your penis coat and auto
paralyze it on
up to ten thousand cores
so i wanted to make you aware of it um
it's uh
the way it actually works is via
a jit compiler similar to number
so you just
put the
photojit
notation around the functions that you
want to auto parallelize and then it
does the work for you
one of the things that we're finding in
some of our early customers like at 7 11
is that
it really cuts down on the amount of
devops engineering you're doing if
you're using
spark sql or pi spark or something and
you need to
you're constantly tweaking the size of
the cluster or
um changing the queries around
uh in production
um that's one of the big benefits of it
is it just
you know takes it takes it directly to
um
machine code that runs on your cluster
so i don't know if that's appropriate
for you i can
let me see if i can share slides real
quick
but um
i'd be real interested in anybody that
uh you know wants to talk to those guys
um
now while i'm at it on the
topic of natural language processing i'm
also working with a company called
irving u r v i n dot ai
we built uh
the
uh
text classification model that
classifies all the
entries on the ebay for tax purposes so
it you know takes any description that
you
that you type in and
[Music]
does that so that's another
um
instance where we're where we're
bringing
uh ai at high scale to
uh bear on these machine learning
problems because
at least what we've seen in production
is when you have these
sometimes you get the machine learning
model and it works great but
uh it doesn't work great uh in
production at scale and i guess i heard
that a little bit in the sense of bill
presentation too and i was wondering if
boto would potentially help you guys i
mean
one of the challenges is when you want
to make things go in real time can you
you know can you accelerate things
enough
and
the core of
sorry it's late the core of what we're
doing with photo is
taking python which is easy to write
pandas which is you know one of the most
popular
libraries
and translating it directly into mpi
which is you know the auto the
parallelization language that most
supercomputers use
so we're
doing all that data engineering for you
in an automatic platform
you can there is a community version of
boto
that's available
really nice lets you auto parallelize on
up to four cores
and then there's also uh an amazon aws
version it's available in the aws
marketplace
and i'll give you four or a few minutes
back i really appreciate the chance to
talk to you guys and look forward we
just moved to raleigh so i'm just
looking forward to you know meeting you
some of you guys in person and getting
to know the data science community here
yeah great to have you matt looking
forward to seeing you in our upcoming
meetings
i look forward to it thanks for having
me
awesome um well thanks everyone um
thanks for joining uh the september
session of the pi data conference um
just a quick reminder that our next
conference is
november 3rd
um
but yeah see everyone there and uh
if nothing else we can end the call
yeah real quick if you want to contact
me i'm just matt mitt photo dot ai
thanks
great
and we are hiring
have a good night
thanks everybody
thank you
bye bye